so Russell Pro is in something called
the loudest voice it's gonna air on
Showtime what a [ __ ] story with this
guy yeah is it is he really that evil
when you when you think about it I mean
the you know movies and TV shows always
have to sort of be a little bit over the
top was the guy that much of a [ __ ]
monster Roger Ailes it's a very
complicated man it's so complicated
because some of its got to do with I
mean think about Roger right right this
is by the way the guy who started Fox
News he dreamt up this whole thing but
by the age of 26 you know they went to
college and stuff and then he was you
know he was a piano player he played
show tunes he always wanted to be on
Broadway by 26 he finds himself the
executive producer of the Mike Douglas
show yeah now so in those years then at
the end of that you know at Mike Douglas
then he goes into the Nixon campaign for
something that he said backstage to
Richard Nixon he made an offhand comment
because Nixon was like going you know
this process of television is like
boring and pointless and blah blah and I
always just had the nuts to turn around
say if you don't begin to understand
television you'll never win another
election in your life I love that story
I mean this guy Ailes had balls
I mean sometimes so inappropriately so I
mean when so inappropriate like he would
walk up to an Arab gentleman and say I
hope you don't fly a plane into one of
our buildings I mean the guy is just
[ __ ] insane but at the same point
it's setting up that stuff there's a lot
of the fun of discovering Roger because
he did a lot of interviews and
conversations and stuff and he'll just
slip in these turns of phrase you know
like if you want to paint your ear and
white and run with the Antelope now's
your chance
you know I don't know that he ever
served in the military or anything like
that he's a guy who's guy who's a
producer in Hollywood for Mike Douglas
and that it seems like he's a guy who
hated Hollywood like he becomes this guy
who hates the Hollywood elite and he
becomes this guy who be create something
that is like bashing Hollywood it's
weird that it doesn't make great TV no I
mean I really is a complicated guy but
that's what makes it interesting to do